looking very dapper by the way all black
thank you yeah I know it's a whole black
thing it's Dior yeah I've been told to
say that the thing is when you're
getting ready for a red carpet like this
like do you like it or do you feel like
this is insane I don't know I think cuz
I was here 16 years ago I was basically
a kid and it kind it was just
overwhelming no I have not so but it's
pretty it's pretty much the same just
more and I think I'm like I'm a grown-up
now so I can handle it a little better I
think the whole last time I was just
like sure sure I have no idea what I did
I have no idea I was kind of drew blank
I was like I have to do an interview and
then suddenly I was sitting down I don't
remember anything else though blacked
out okay yeah yeah and I hadn't had a
drink yet
what were you at the globe's for that I
was nominated for movie called egg be
Goes Down and actually I think about it
I was under 21 so I couldn't even drink
fasters anything can happen at the
Golden Globes having a drink tonight one
how does it feel to be nominated it's
pretty cool like I'd like I said like
I'm I was overwhelmed last time so this
time it's just kind of different and
wildly unexpected I wasn't even sure
that her show was eligible this year for
it not I'm not even kidding and then I
got a call about it happening and I was
like none of this makes sense I like
everyone's mess with me right now I need
to like check this all right Google says
it's true if we have Google I do have a
speech prepared no no no my theory with
that is this every time I started to
prepare a speech it made me nervous and
I go well most likely even just by odds
I'm not gonna win so if I this actually
makes sense if I prepare something and
don't win I've spent all this time being
nervous for no reason if I don't prepare
I feel good I'm gonna have a nice time
and the worst case scenario is I win
self-preservation right just trying not
to freak out just how did the family
react and you told them yeah pretty cool
I still didn't like it was like five in
the morning and I was getting all these
texts I'm like I think all of you are
wrong
this doesn't sound right I mean some big
moments for other members of the family
- your brother redoing a home alone for
that commercial
all of that when when he told you about
it were you like yes awesome would she
react to see he told me he was doing a
Google ad and that they were working out
the deal and all that stuff and I
thought cool so then about a week after
they shot it it was already put together
he showed me he did not tell me what the
concept was so I was like oh my god this
is this is amazing I kept saying like
this is a thing like people are gonna
love this this is like a real thing how
cool is it did it blow your mind the
detail I'm watching you like the
side-by-side looks great I heard I'm not
sure if it's true that they like
actually got the original lens that they
shot the film on to shoot the Adhan I'm
not sure if that's true I probably
should verify that first I'm saying it
on camera well I loved that he did it
cuz the fans loved it so much I mean
what is that like for you guys because
you're both in the movie and I'm you
know every Christmas it's like people
watch it does it get are you like oh my
gosh we get it it sort of surprised me
that he did it that he went back to that
Garrett yeah it wasn't like I don't know
it was a it was a movie for us to
growing up which is funny like you know
you would think that because you know he
was in it it was such a big thing that
like we wouldn't be able to enjoy it
like a Christmas movie but over the
years we have been able to you watch it
yeah we watch it I haven't watched it in
the last couple Christmases sort of like
Christmas story like I used to watch it
every year now it's like I need I need a
break every couple years before I can
watch this one again but we watch it
it's like you have somebody a friend of
ours comments it goes that I think it's
so cool that your family sits around and
actually watches home alone like it's a
good Christmas movie well you want me to
say
you